tamo moon SOT Chien grande good engine
in my view the various changes and
reforms that I have outlined in my
address to the nation such as the
overhaul of our safety culture as well
as reform of our civil service can't be
regarded as a complete distinction to
our efforts to revitalize our economy
and to lay a robust foundation for our
economy
sinem Bonilla County when I unveiled my
three-year plan for economic innovation
at the outset of this year the
overarching goal the primary objective
was to normalize abnormality that has
been rampant in our society there by
cementing the fundamentals of economic
foundation second was to promote a
creative economy and third was to ensure
greater balance in terms of our domestic
demands and export and so in terms of
putting wrongs to right that has been
missing in our society we must endeavor
to weed out our society's deep-rooted
ills that are rampant in Korean society
so efforts to normalize abnormality will
be addressing these issues we believe in
that progress we can further strengthen
the foundations of our economy if we
faithfully implement these reform
efforts I believe we can look forward to
a stronger economy and look forward to
revitalizing our economy for these
reform efforts will be very helpful in
that regard
in any event these are efforts we must
seek to undertake
the Lord had an American email another
nuclear test conducted by North Korea
would basically make the six-party talks
really lose their point and indeed North
Korea would effectively be crossing the
Rubicon if they were to conduct another
nuclear test
the Chinese have also expressed their
resolute opposition to another nuclear
test by North Korea and have firmly
expressed their commitment that they
won't accept a nuclear-armed North Korea
and the Chinese have worked very hard to
this effect China's role continues to
remain very important I see this for
many reasons including the fact that
China accounts for about 90 percent of
North Korea's external trade thus it
exerts considerable economic influence
over North Korea so even as we go
forward the Chinese will be vital we are
working with other member states of the
six-party talks to make sure that North
Korea denuclearize and to uphold the
fact that we will not accept a
nuclear-armed North Korea we are
engaging in consultations on various
ways to make substantial progress in
this regard
younggu kor doeng jungle killing dinner
with regard to the South China Sea and
East China Sea issue
the Korean government does watch this
issue with considerable concern with
regard to the East China Sea issue in
particular we are carefully monitoring
the abiding state of tension and
conflict among the relevant countries
and we are watching it with serious
concern and in particular I would note
that the East China Sea has implications
for Korea's economic interest maritime
transportation and air defense as well
so it does have implications for Korea's
interests as well and we hope to see the
relevant countries deal with this issue
smoothly through dialogue as for the
South China Sea any significant dispute
shouldn't break out in the South China
Sea because that would undermine peace
and stability in the asia-pacific region
moreover the South China Sea is also
important for Korea for its major sea
transportation route thus we watch this
area with concern as well and we hope
that the relevant countries will be able
to deal with this issue in accordance
with international law as well as the
Declaration on the conduct of parties in
the South China Sea
- needle t motion Yahoo not a lobotomy
Jamie Muro Kamui even in the case of
Germany people weren't sure really when
the unification would come some said
maybe ten years later but really the
German unification came out of the blue
so even in the case of Korea likewise
there's really no knowing when
unification would in fact come so the
most important thing for us is to make
sure we do our best to prepare for the
day of unification what we need in this
process is not just for South and North
Korea's to work together but also we
need to work together with neighboring
countries and we also need the support
and assistance of the international
community and as we seek to aspire to
peaceful unification of the Korean
Peninsula what's most important is to
question what vision will be guiding our
aspirations and indeed share a vision
that unification would not just be about
overcoming physical division of the
Korean Peninsula but also contributing
to peace and prosperity of Northeast
Asia and around the world